[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
émission spéciale consacrée à la fin de
vie c'est l'ultime demande mourir
paisiblement sans trop souffrir mais
est-ce vraiment possible dans notre pays
est-ce qu'on meurt mal aujourd'hui en
France en 2023 il va y avoir une
nouvelle loi Emmanuel Macron la promise
oui mais laquelle l'aide active à mourir
est-elle l'étape à franchir comme vient
de le préconiser la convention citoyenne
question grave sujet intime douloureux
universel qui mêle l'éthique à la
politique bonsoir Alain Cleis bonsoir et
merci beaucoup d'être notre grand témoin
ce soir vous êtes l'auteur avec Jean
Leonetti de la loi de 2016 la dernière
loi sur la fin de vie membre aujourd'hui
du Comité consultatif national des
tiques bonsoir claire Toury ravi de vous
accueillir vous présidez le comité de
gouvernance de la convention citoyenne
sur la fin de vie vous avez guidé les
quatre mois de travaux des 184 citoyens
qui viennent de rendre leur proposition
bonsoir Olivier Faverney bonsoir
bienvenue député MoDem président de la
mission parlementaire d'évaluation de la
loi classes Léonetti favorable à l'aide
active à mourir bonsoir Philippe
Gosselin ravi de vous accueillir député
les républicains de la Manche opposés à
l'évolution de la loi et il nous fallait
un philosophe pour ce premier plateau
bonsoir Éric fourneret spécialiste de la
question de l'euthanasie on va commencer
avec la convention citoyenne c'est un
exercice passionnant inédit de
démocratie 184 citoyens tirés au sort
qui ont accepté de travailler sur leur
temps libre sur ce cadre législatif de
la fin de vie et sur ses évolutions
possibles alors certains n'y
connaissaient absolument rien d'autres
sont arrivés vous allez le voir avec
leur propre conviction d'autres ont
carrément changé d'avis quand la
démocratie se fait convention citoyenne
s'est un reportage de Céline Crespy avec
Cléa Jouanneau et Bertrand Martineau
regardait on débat juste après
durant 4 mois le Conseil économique et
social a été le théâtre d'un exercice
démocratique inhabituel sur une question
à la fois intime et universelle
184 citoyens ont dû statuer sur la façon
dont on peut mourir aujourd'hui dans
notre pays
ils ont entre 20 et 86 ans sont
d'origine géographique et sociale très
différentes et ont été tirés au sort
certains n'en reviennent toujours pas
on a tous cru que c'était un gag du
démarchage téléphonique
parce que voilà c'est assez incroyable
finalement on est 185 sur la totalité de
la population française oui ça c'est
incroyable après 9 week-end de travail
ils devront dire si la loi actuelle sur
la fin de vie leur paraît satisfaisante
ou s'il faudrait l'élargir c'est
l'aspect de la démocratie participative
et même au-delà de la démocratie du
fonctionnement de démocratie qui qui
m'intéresse qui m'intéresse beaucoup je
pense qu'on fera absolument capable de
construire un avis
solide qui sera argumenté qui sera dans
les conditions apaisées qui sera
à mon avis à ses proches de ce qu'est la
réalité en tout cas de ce que je peux
pas être l'opinion dans tous les esprits
cette question dans quelle mesure leur
délibération vont être entendues par le
politique la convention citoyenne sur le
climat a laissé des traces
pour les rassurer la Présidence de
l'Assemblée nationale a voulu clarifier
leur rôle
donc ce sera pris en compte soyez-en
certains et je pense qu'il n'y aura pas
un parlementaire qui n'aura pas lu
toutes les chaque page chaque ligne
chaque mot de vos délibérations vous
allez être une pierre de ce processus
délibératif le mur nous allons
construire ensemble vous apporterez des
pierres l'Assemblée nationale en
apportera le gouvernement n'apportera le
Sénat en apportera et tous ensemble on
va construire
vous voyez et moi c'est ça pourquoi je
crois
[Applaudissements]
mais avant tout rappel de ce que dit la
loi actuelle sur la fin de vie
[Musique]
à l'encaisse donc à l'anglais s'il a été
député entre 87 et 2017 co-auteur de la
bonjour
et à tous les citoyens vont apprendre
que cette loi autorise dans certains cas
le recours à la sédation profonde et
continue
lorsque une personne
est
et dont le pronostic vital est engagé à
court terme
le patient à personne
[Musique]
et elle ne se réveille pas à se dire
qu'on l'accompagne dans ces derniers
moments
pour retirer pour éviter les douleurs
rêves dans la terre nous apportons
[Musique]
cette sédation n'est possible qu'en face
terminale quand le patient est certain
de décéder à court terme les citoyens
réalisent qu’elle est très restrictive
pourquoi certains patients attendent
neurogénéité générative telle que la
maladie de Charcot est Parkinson était
exclu du cadre de cette voie
de ce qu'on appelle l'aide active à
mourir
chacun arrive avec ses références sa
culture ses croyances il me semble
complètement anormal que des citoyens
français aisés puissent aller en Suisse
en Belgique en Espagne au Portugal
comme le faisait les femmes il y a 5 ans
ou 60 ans pour interrompre
une grossesse mettant leur vie en danger
sans anormal
que que nous soyons dans cette situation
d'autres ont vécu particuliers et des
opinions bien tranchées j'aimerais que
chaque fois existe j'ai la sclérose en
plaques et je me suis toujours dit que
je n'aimerais pas terminer
dans un lit
sans savoir trop bouger au départ je
suis plutôt contre je pense que avec des
soins palliatifs plus performants il y
aurait quand même beaucoup de situations
où les gens pourraient vivre encore
quelques mois quelques jours et parfois
ces jours là ils sont fondamentaux
justement le week-end suivant ils vont
pouvoir appréhender les modèles choisis
par la Belgique et la Suisse quand elles
ont légalisé l'aide actifs à mourir
j'appelle
tout de suite
donc je travaille en Belgique depuis 30
ans dans le cadre
un patient majeur capable et conscient
et un patient mineur ça a été une
évolution en 2014
à condition qu'il y a une capacité de
discernement
la demande est formulée de manière
volontaire réfléchie et répétée et le
patient se trouve dans une situation
médicale sans issue
et fait état une souffrance physique ou
psychique constante insupportable qui ne
peut être apaisé nous avons énormément
de demandes d'euthanasie et peu d'acte
de thanazisme beaucoup ont entendu
parler de la mort de Jean-Luc Godard ce
jour-là il découvre le modèle suisse
celui du suicide assisté où le patient
se donne lui-même la mort et où les
associations comme Dignitas jouent un
rôle majeur
et pour être en mesure de faire la
posture la personne doit avoir un
immense de votre propriété corporelle
c'est fini en charge de procurer les
médicaments les femmes pour les
personnes ne réside pas en Suisse c'est
un peu plus de 10 000
je vois déjà que d'un côté en Suisse on
a une association alors que de l'autre
côté en Belgique c'est vraiment le
système et l'organisation sanitaire qui
s'occupe et qui se préoccupe de ça j'ai
trouvé que le schéma belge était
intéressant parce qu'il mettait le
médecin traitant au cœur du système
le sujet interroge même après deux
heures de conférence les citoyens
veulent prolonger le moment que se
passe-t-il par exemple en cas de maladie
dégénérative moi j'ai dans la vie des
gens qui jusqu'au bout me disent c'est
ça que je veux docteur c'est la grosse
question de la démence actuellement pour
les familles qui disent mais maman quand
elle quand elle a eu son diagnostic elle
a dit si j'ai une démence je mourrais
par eux dans la vie et maintenant
maintenant
et elle le demande plus et nous on la
voit se dégrader et c'est pas digne et
elle a fait une déclaration anticipée
mais bientôt les citoyens vont faire
face à des mots qui vont les faire
vaciller cet après-midi là médecin et
infirmière en soins palliatifs
témoignent leur message est simple avant
de vouloir changer la loi encore
faudrait-il l'appliquer
faute de lit deux tiers des personnes
gravement malades meurent sans avoir
accès aux soins palliatifs
[Musique]
et les familles elles m'ont dit aussi
pourquoi la loi elle n'est pas appliquée
pourquoi les gens n'ont pas accès aux
soins politiques ce qui manque aux
soignants que nous sommes c'est le temps
à accompagner justement à être
présent quant à la possibilité de
permettre l'aide d'activer à mourir elle
leur paraît contre nature
[Musique]
c'est pas possible pour moi c'est juste
pas possible du tout du tout du tout du
tout du tout du tout
selon ses soignants les demandes de
thanazie des passions baisseraient quand
la prise en charge en soins palliatifs
est efficiente
ça m'interpelle quand même sur des
choses que j'avais pas imaginer si les
problématiques ne sont pas déjà réglés à
la base c'est à dire le manque de
personnel le manque de moyens le manque
de formation comment on peut évoluer
dans la dans la décision dans la
question qui nous est posée on a eu une
quasi uneanimité des soignants donc
médecins infirmières accompagnant
contre l'euthanasie
ouais ça je peux le dire moi ça m'a ça
m'a bouleversé
après ce week-end les conventionnelles
réalisent plus que jamais à quel point
la question qu'on leur a posé complexe
et multiforme
retour au débat nous sommes début
janvier les citoyens vont être plongés
dans le grand bain des arguments pour ou
contre l'aide active à mourir avec un
face à face d'étonnant
[Musique]
commune des soins palliatifs
ne peuvent pas tout
très difficile et si les soignants
partent aussi serrés actuellement c'est
parce que ce qu'on leur demande
actuellement n'a pas de sens pour eux si
les soins palliatifs ne peuvent pas tout
et si la loi aujourd'hui de perdrait pas
pour la DMD et pour beaucoup de Français
d'accompagner tous les parcours en fin
de vie ils souhaitons aussi aller
légalisation de l'élève qui va mourir de
l'euthanasie et du suicide assisté c'est
seulement 2% de l'ensemble du secteur de
champ magnétique qui nous disent qu'ils
peuvent envisager les frénésie 2% ce
n'est pas demain les mec qui va mourir
pour tout et pour tous fort heureusement
mais ce qu'on souhaite c'est que chacun
puisse avoir son choix à partir du
moment où il y a une loi tous les toutes
les personnes sont obligées de
l'envisager c'est-à-dire que la présence
de la loi
fait que chacun va être amené à se
demander si ce serait mieux pour lui
pour ses proches pour la société qu'il
fasse ce choix là je ne suis pas le
méchant qui vient dire ta vie de combat
on va te donner des mourir parce que tu
as demandé des actives à mourir on peut
partir dans toutes ces théories là sauf
que on va dans un débat inverse moi je
vous propose
[Musique]
dans deux semaines vont commencer les
phases de délibération chaque citoyen
doit se forger un avis mais c'est pas
je me nourris de
tout je pense que c'est important
ok là pendant les deux premières
sessions et c'était nécessaire je crois
que ça arrive maintenant qu'on est
justement ce début de débat
contradictoire avec des positions qui
commencent à s'affronter il y a des
oscillations ah oui tiens ah bah c'est
pas fausse qu'il a dit et puis après
quelqu'un va venir donner un
contre-exemple c'est un peu les
montagnes russes émotionnelles quand
même
mais avant de trancher la délicate
question de l'aide active à mourir les
citoyens veulent interpeller le
politique sur ce qui leur paraît être un
impératif absolu depuis des semaines
quel que soit leur opinion les
participants sont frappés par un constat
le traitement de la douleur
l'accompagnement vers la mort ne sont
pas à la hauteur des besoins faute de
moyens
la fin de la vie se rapproche il faut
qu'il on ait besoin d'anticiper cette
fin de vie
d'atelier en atelier l'état des lieux
est alarmant
que 50 médecins où il en manque 5000 il
manque une unité de son palatif ou en
manque 10 20 ans les médecins sont un
peu aussi forcés par le système de
l'hôpital à ne pas passer du temps
beaucoup de temps avec les patients et
plutôt à faire des actes tout ça
d'autant que dans les années à venir les
besoins de soins palliatifs vont être
exponentielles
il y a 10% de gens qui ont plus de 75
ans actuellement mais il y en aura 20%
dans quelques années
pourquoi parce que c'est les progrès de
la médecine
alors ils vont s'entendre sur près de 65
mesures concrètes à remettre à la
première ministre pour que les soins
palliatifs ne soient plus le parent
pauvre de l'hôpital
proposition 26
pour chaque région des objectifs des
couvertures exhaustives besoin est
disponibilité en soif pagatif pour 100%
de la population de la région le vote
est ouvert aujourd'hui encore plus d'une
vingtaine de départements sont
totalement dépourvues d'unités de soins
palliatifs
[Musique]
la proposition d'activité avec 60%
obligé les EHPAD avoir vu personnel
formé en soi palliatif
les EHPAD sont démunies de soins
palliatifs alors que c'est l'endroit où
meurt 20 % des Français
la proposition est acceptée à 41% dans
le cadre d'une sédation profonde et
continue à domicile
renforcer l'accompagnement des proches
le bonnes nouvelles car aujourd'hui les
procédons sont les grands oubliés de la
loi
la conscience
désormais reste le sujet qui fâche le
plus clivant celui de l'aide activa
mourir les citoyens ont planché par
groupe pour lister les conditions qui
seraient indispensables selon eux pour
pouvoir prétendre à l'aide active à
mourir
finalement aux arguments sur l'accès à
la rédactive à mourir tous s'entendent
pour dire que le patient doit avoir son
libre arbitre mais faut-il par exemple
qu'il soit condamné
on s'est dit que dès qu'on ait la notion
d'incurementée
de situation
[Musique]
un peu de nature
autre question très clivante cet acte
peut-il être possible pour des mineurs
[Musique]
pourquoi on pourrait satisfaire une
demande d'un épuisant et pas celle d'un
enfant
avec mes parents sont fait dans ce cas
on va commencer par les lister
et que dire des dépressifs chroniques
qui demanderaient une euthanasie ça
m'interroge sur sur des maladies ou
l'envie de mourir la pensée suicidaire
est un symptôme à part entière de la
maladie s'appelle le cas de cet homme
dépressif sévère est-ce que finalement
redaction va mourir n'est pas une façon
un peu radicale de soigner ce symptôme
je pose la question
les débats sont vifs débordant même le
cadre de l'hémicycle
au vu du rap forcément des évolutions
qui vont être amenées il y a une
position hypocrite qui serait d'autres
ouvrir la porte en disant oui mais on va
la barricader à quelques cas tout en
sachant pertinemment qu'en fait c'est
qu'avant inéluctablement sauter par
l'évolution de la loi par l'évolution de
la société plus qu'un week-end pour
finaliser leur recommandation
dernier jour de l'ultime session et le
vote d'un texte de 150 pages argumentées
pour créer un modèle français de l'aide
active à mourir
[Musique]
à 97% que le cadre d'accompagnement de
la fin de vie doit être améliorée pour
76% d'entre nous l'accès à l'aide active
à mourir doit être ouvert concernant les
formes d'accès à l'aide activement vivre
la convention citoyenne avait émergé une
position majoritaire celle de la
nécessité de mettre en place suicide
assister et euthanasie avec de
nombreuses nuances reflet de la
complexité du sujet
pour y avoir accès le patient devrait
avoir une maladie incurable et faire
preuve de discernement en revanche pour
les mineurs c'est non pour ne pas
heurter les soignants les citoyens leur
ont donné une échappatoire
concernant l'implication des personnels
soignants la convention à adopter le
principe d'une chlorure de conscience
au final
684 là ont l'impression d'avoir vécu un
moment privilégié grâce à la Convention
c'était génial parce que c'est quelque
chose d'unique dans une vie de pouvoir
réfléchir avec autant de monde et
d'arriver à le faire et de voir qu'à la
fin on a réussi à construire quelque
chose de cohérent c'est une aventure
extraordinaire ça bouscule on se
retrouve avec des gens qu'on aimerait
qu'on n'aurait jamais rencontré
autrement je crois que je ne saisis
toujours pas je ne réalise toujours pas
d'avoir participé à ça mais ça fait ça
fait quelque chose par an
un processus plein d'enseignement
au-delà même du thème de la fin de vie
sur la démocratie ça nous dit beaucoup
de choses finalement quand on nous en
donne l'opportunité quand on donne la
parole et qu'on nous fait confiance on
est capable de produire quelque chose et
on a envie de le produire et c'est ça
qui est très beau j'espère que ça
continuera avec Laura d'autres
conventions citoyennes pour traiter des
sujets aussi importants et peut-être
difficile avec le même respect moi je me
dis comme mes collègues la convention se
termine mais et on continue et on espère
que nous le débat s'ouvrira bien
évidemment au Parlement
les cartes sont désormais entre les
mains du Président de la République
un texte devrait être présenté devant
l'Assemblée nationale avant la fin de
l'été
[Musique]
et voilà donc pour ce premier reportage
de la soirée signé Céline crispy en
plateau toujours en compagnie d'Alain
Claye merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
donc l'auteur avec Jean Leonetti de la
loi de 2016 vous êtes aussi membre du
Comité national consultatif des tickets
qui a rendu un rapport à un avis très
important dont on va parler ce soir
claire Touri qu'on a vu dans ce
reportage chef d'orchestre de cette
convention citoyenne Olivier falornier
député MoDem qui a piloté la mission
d'évaluation de cette loi Léonetti qui
milite pour l'aide active à mourir
Philippe Gosselin toujours député les
républicains de la Manche toujours
au fil à la dactive à mourir et puis
Eric fournirait philosophe spécialiste
de ces questions sommes-nous libres de
vouloir mourir rien que le titre il faut
prendre le temps voilà de le décanter
c'était chez Albin Michel en 2019 ancien
membre de la commission Sicard de 2012
sur la fin de vie on va commencer avec
vous claire Toury c'est absolument pass
de voir cet exercice de maïeutique cet
exercice démocratique il y a eu le temps
de l'appropriation de la délibération
puis des propositions vous avez tous
suivi qu'est-ce que vous retenez quel
bilan vous tirez de ces quatre mois oui
c'est assez émouvant de regarder le
reportage de voir tout le cheminement je
faisais des commentaires sur le
changement de coupe de cheveux entre le
9 décembre et le 2 avril qui voit qu'on
a qui montre qu'on a quand même passé du
temps c'est neuf weekend vous le disiez
c'est 27 jours de travail
194ans qui viennent d'horizons
complètement différents qui ont accepté
de donner beaucoup de leur temps
beaucoup d'engagement mais surtout un
peu de même moi c'est un peu ça que je
retiens de l'exercice qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire c'est un peu de même la
question de la fin de vie ça croise
trois choses pour moi enfin la question
de la fin de vie et l'exercice
démocratique ensemble ça croise trois
choses premièrement il y a un enjeu
politique parce qu'il faut qu'on arrive
ensemble à fixer un cadre collectif il y
a un enjeu intime on parle de la fin de
vie ça veut dire qu'on vient échanger
avec des gens qu'on connaît pas qu'on
reverra peut-être jamais et avec qui on
accepte de partager ce qu'on a pu vivre
au plus profond quoi sont des
représentations un vécu des émotions de
l'affect et ça ça fait partie des
premières choses qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
fait ensemble en arrivant le problème
ils ont échangé entre eux ils ont
partagé ce qu'ils avaient vécu leurs
expériences de fin de vie ou leur
représentation de fin de vie je peux
vous dire que ça pose les bases en fait
quand vous avez des gens qui vous
racontent ça et que voilà tout de suite
il y a un respect qui s'impose et on
peut pas faire n'importe quoi sur un
sujet comme celui-ci qui est hautement
sensible vraiment hautement sensible et
qui nécessite beaucoup d'exigences et
troisième élément troisième facteur je
pense de réussite en tout cas c'est
comme ça que j'ai envie de qualifier cet
exercice à cette date de de la
convention c'est le fait d'avoir bien
conscience que la démocratie ben c'est
du travail en fait mais je pense que je
peux pas le dire autrement c'est pas
juste des paillettes voilà on retient
que c'est magnifique qui s'est passé
quelque chose de formidable mais tout ça
c'est beaucoup de travail fait du
travail et c'est pas binaire pour ou
contre c'est pas prendre du temps ça
prend du temps et c'est accepter qu'on
peut faire des erreurs et qu'on doit
cheminer ensemble pour essayer de les
dépasser vous parlez le tour de force
démocratique ça veut dire quoi arriver à
un consensus absolu sur un sujet comme
celui-ci c'était de fait impossible ah
mais c'était de fait impossible et c'est
pas grave en fait je pense que c'est là
le tour de force démocratique mais on
l'avait dit vous m'aviez invité la
veille du lancement de la convention je
me souviens et on l'avait dit en fait le
cet exercice c'est assumer la
controverse sur la fente vie on peut pas
dire à certains qu'ils ont tort et à
d'autres qu'ils ont raison et en fait
dire ça c'est déjà à mon avis dire
beaucoup de choses parce que ça veut
dire que l'exercice a été abordé en
acceptant la nuance et on se disant
qu'il pouvait il ne pouvait pas en être
autrement et là où pour moi c'est un une
réussite c'est quand les dix
minoritaires les 25% qui sont contre
toute forme d'active à mourir refuse de
faire un rapport minoritaire ils veulent
être dans le livrable dans le document
final au même titre que les autres et
ils veulent que leurs arguments soient
mis en miroir de ceux des autres et il y
a une conventionnelle en conclusion de
la convention dimanche qui a pris la
parole et qui dit
elle était dans les minoritaires et elle
dit merci à tous d'avoir laissé les 25%
d'entre nous dit minoritaires d'avoir
laissé au 25 % d'entre nous 10
minoritaires 50% de la parole et 50% de
la place et ça pour moi ça a dit tout en
fait c'est le signe déjà d'un succès
exactement même si il va falloir poser
la question de la suite alors on vous a
vu à l'inclès au CESU vous avez dû
expliquer la loi qu'est-ce que vous
retenez des échanges avec les citoyens
une intelligence collective chacun et
chacune est arrivée avec son vécu avec
ses mots
ignorant de toutes les procédures de fin
de vie et ces intelligences collectives
c'est concrétisée par un mot qui à mon
avis dans cette période on doit tous
avoir en tête le respect
sur un sujet comme cela il ne peut pas y
avoir de gagnants ou de perdants le
respect des autres ou le respect des
malades
c'est-à-dire de celui qui ne pense pas
comme vous du soignant de la famille
bref cette communauté qui existe et qui
est très singulière dans chaque cas dans
cette dernière partie de la vie j'ai
regardé la loi classe Léonetti elle
s'est appuyée sur des auditions
d'experts
c'est que le lieu
le plus adapté pour faire la loi c'est
pas le référendum c'est la démocratie
représentative c'est-à-dire le Parlement
l'Assemblée et le Sénat et on peut la
compléter mais pour éclairer cette
réflexion qu'une convention citoyenne
comme celle-ci est Dieu et moi je veux
témoigner qu'elle a été lieu à a eu lieu
en dehors de toute pression en dehors et
la presse en rang parfaitement compte je
pense que c'est un atout pour notre
on sent bien évidemment cette question
de la fin de vie et l'affaire de tous
mais la manière de décider sur un sujet
comme celui-ci est très important est-ce
que vous y voyez un tournant le fait
qu'on ait commencé par demander aux
citoyens que ça commence par la
délibération citoyenne et qu'ensuite le
législateur les ministres les experts
rajoutent la éclairage
ce qui est nouveau avec la convention
citoyenne c'est la méthodologie avec
laquelle les citoyens sont venus
délibérés parce qu'en 2012 qu'en
François Hollande a leur président de la
République avait mis en place la
Commission sur la fin de vie présidée
par le professeur Sicard on était déjà
allé à la rencontre des citoyens
français on avait fait le tour de
l'Europe en Italie outre-Atlantique pour
observer les pratiques de ceux qui
avaient déjà autorisé les gestes
euthanasie qui suicide assisté mais on
avait déjà été à la rencontre des
Français pour qu'il puisse s'exprimer la
grosse différence qui est là c'est que
les citoyens on les a mis autour d'une
table pour qu'ils travaillent pas
simplement qu'il pas simplement venir
témoigner mais qui vient de travailler
sur le sujet et la grosse différence et
le gros apport ici de la convention
citoyenne c'est celui-là c'est la notion
de travail qui a derrière c'est des gens
qui ont pu comme Madame la très bien dit
qui ont énormément évolué dans les mois
qui ont cheminé
justement au débat c'est ce cheminement
là d'ailleurs c'est intéressant de voir
que les résultats des des propositions
76% des conventionnelles favorables à
l'aide acti à mourir on retrouve
les sondages d'opinion c'était 70% selon
un dernier sondage alors maintenant
Olivier falleroni dans quelle mesure et
bien les propositions de cette
convention engagent le législateur je
crois que effectivement il y a eu un
passage de relais lundi entre la
démocratie participative et la
démocratie représentative et quand je
vois l'hémicycle du CESU
et bien je pense aux autres chers
collègues qui ferait bien de s'inspirer
je crois en tout cas de la façon dont
les conventionnelles ont travaillé
Alain évoquait l'écoute dans le respect
des convictions de chacun une pierre
l'édifice aujourd'hui il y aura d'autres
pierres ou c'est le socle vraiment
indispensable primordial pour légiférer
je vous le dis d'autant plus facilement
et avec d'autant plus de sincérité que
je faisais partie des sceptiques quand
cette convention citoyenne a été a été
mise en place d'abord parce que la
convention citoyenne sur climat n'avait
pas été forcément couronnée de succès et
puis je ne voyais pas comment tout cela
aurait pouvait s'organiser donc coup de
chapeau à claires Toury coup de chapeau
ses œufs parce que vraiment ils ont fait
un travail formidable mais ce que je
veux dire au-delà c'est que certes il y
a eu la convention citoyenne il y a eu
aussi le rapport du
du comité d'éthique qui a été majeur
mais est-ce que vous vous sentez vous
comme député engagés par les
préconisations
c'est une obligation morale et je crois
que si
la démocratie représentative le
Parlement le gouvernement ne suit pas
les préconisations de cette convention
citoyenne et bien il y aura à nouveau
une déception une déception forte de la
part non seulement de ceux qui sont
engagés les 184 mais plus globalement
les Français qu'il représentaient
quelque part dans finalement le choix
qui avait été fait Philippe Gosselin
c'est une obligation morale que de
suivre ces travaux c'est une vraie
question moi je n'ai pas de difficulté à
voir une convention citoyenne se réunir
on rappellera du reste que pour la
révision des lois de bioéthique on a eu
des États généraux qui associer très
largement aussi la population les
associations alors sous un mode
différent de travail ce que je souhaite
et c'est la même obligation morale c'est
qu'on puisse avoir un débat apaisé je
rejoins ce que disait Olivier Falorni
parce que sur ces questions c'est pas
blanc c'est pas noir parfois ça peut
être gris on a tendance à vous enfermer
parce que vous êtes de telles
confessions de tels groupes politiques
dans une obstination des raisonnable
pour le oui pour le nom c'est plus
complexe que sait-on de la vie de
chacune et chacun d'entre nous
parlementaire de notre vie privée nos
intimes convictions dans le shaker vous
savez il y a plusieurs ingrédients il y
a pas qu'une religion il y a pas qu'une
philosophie un courant de pensée c'est
beaucoup plus complexe et là où je ne
voudrais pas qu'on soit dans une
continuité absolue avec la convention
c'est que je voudrais que nous aussi à
l'Assemblée et dans des conditions
apaisées nous puissions débattre
c'est-à-dire pas nécessairement écarté
d'un revers de main ce qui a été dit et
des conclusions qui sortent elles sont
là de toute façon le président de la
République a dit que c'était les bases
les bases
solides
pas nécessairement obligatoire d'avoir
ces fondations et le mur qui célébrait
pile poil sur ses fondations à nous
aussi peut-être de contredire certains
points de les enrichir de les préciser
c'est ça le vrai débat on va venir sur
le fond et et je termine juste sur ce
point c'est pour ça que si on veut un
débat apaisé vous faut un débat sans
précipitation oui il y a une attente de
la société pour que sans doute les
textes évoluent mais étant à quelques
deux ou trois mois près je pense que non
donc il va falloir
on va voir avant la fin de l'été c'est
trop rapide ça fait 4 mois d'ici à la
fin de l'été une un projet de loi mais
encore faut-il faire vivre le débat
démocratique à l'intérieur même du
Parlement c'est pas que l'assemblée
c'est aussi le Sénat qu'on puisse
réexpertiser un certain nombre de choses
et qu'on puisse à la rentrée en effet
avoir des débats sans que ait une
procédure accélérée sans qu'on ait cette
épée de Damoclès je crois ça serait
contre-productible
transpartisane comme ça se fait sur les
sujets des commissions spéciales au sein
de la tourisme d'autres sujets c'est
important pour rester présidente du
comité de gouvernance pour la suite
est-ce qu'il y a une vigilance qu'est-ce
qui se passe côté convention maintenant
que vous avez fini les travaux alors mon
mot ça va s'arrêter quand même pour nous
nous le on considère qu'on a fait notre
part on va dire qu'on a fait tout ce
qu'on pouvait on est allé au bout il y
avait un enjeu à ce que cet exercice
démocratique il soit incontestable sur
le plan de la méthode je pense que ça
c'était vraiment très important sur le
fond moi j'ai pas vraiment à commenter
ce qui a été dit si ce n'est que encore
une fois il y a des bases solides il y a
une partie qui est très consensuelle
quand même dans le rapport on parle
d'active amoureux mais il y a une partie
pour renforcer exactement il y a une
partie plus de controverse qui est
argumenté qui est solide mon enjeu enfin
moi je vous rejoins il y a jamais eu
d'engagement à ce que tout soit repris
de manière
intelligence
majeure entre tout reprendre et ne rien
reprendre du tout moi ce qui m'importe
c'est que c'est 184 citoyens citoyens
ils aient des réponses et qu'on prenne
en compte leur travail parce que je vais
citer le président du CESU la décision
elle appartient aux élus il y a pas de
doute là-dessus la construction de la
décision la partie à tout le monde et
ses citoyens ils ont quand même démontré
qu'on pouvait le faire en étant alors
justement si les citoyens se prononcent
en faveur de l'aide active à mourir
c'est qu'il existe des situations à la
classe dans lesquelles votre loi ne
suffit pas est-ce que vous le
reconnaissez on pense à la maladie de
Charcot les maladies neurodégénératives
il y a des cas
ou le pronostic vital qui est engagé
n'est pas engagé à court terme mais
peut-être un moyen terme vous évoquez
à mourir nous l'avons répondu à cette
question dans la vie du comité
nationalétique oui il y a une voie
éthique mais avec un encadrement très
strict que nous avons évoqué le
la convention citoyenne a fait la même
chose mais tout le travail commence car
c'est maintenant au législateur et à
l'exécutif car le président de la
République a souhaité une coproduction
de mesurer dans cette aide active à
mourir quel est son périmètre quels sont
les quatre traités et je crois que c'est
pas un sujet qu'on traite dans un
olivier falornier la vie du conseil
consultatif d'éthique ouvre la voie et
c'est prudent et extrêmement mesuré à
des pathologies nouvelles quand le
pronostic vital est engagé à moyen terme
et non plus à court terme comme c'est
dans la loi kless Leonetti est-ce que ça
vous semble la la fenêtre équilibrée
pour ouvrir l'aide active à mourir tout
à fait cela me semblerait absolument
justifier dans dans le répare dans le
rapport d'évaluation que nous avons
produit il y a quelques jours qui est
vocale inclès effectivement nous
indiquons que aujourd'hui la sédation
profonde et continue maintenant décès et
finalement assez peu appliqué pourquoi
on veut comprendre d'abord on a un vrai
souci en termes d'évaluation
quantitative c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de codification
des actes c'est-à-dire que le ministère
de la Santé on n'a pas de bilan
jusqu'au décès sont appliqués pourquoi
sur le pourquoi il y a pas de chiffres
il y a un tabou là dessus alors il y a
deux réponses à ça il y a deux réponses
à ça
d'une part certains nous disent parce
que finalement cet outil
n'est que celui du dernier recours et
qui n'est pas
utile dans l'immense majorité des cas
d'autres nous disent qu'ils posent plus
de problèmes que de solutions parce que
il y a la difficulté d'abord de la
maîtrise du temps
on a l'impression que ce débat chaque
mot compte chaque mot doit couvrir
précisément et avec justesse la réalité
déjà parlé de droit on entend ouvrir un
nouveau droit est-ce que ça vous semble
mot approprié où il s'agit d'une liberté
pour toutes ces patients avec les
critères stricts qu'il faut toujours
rappeler s'il y a énormément de
garde-fous qui souhaitent mourir pour au
fond abréger leur souffrance ne pas
faire subir à leurs proches leurs
déchéance cette question que vous posez
elle rejoint celle que vous avez posée
juste avant c'est à dire que
juste avant vous allez demander si par
exemple la Malaisie de Charcot était ses
exceptions pathologiques qui
justifierait justement qu'on ouvre la
légalité entre autres et le piège c'est
et ça rejoint votre second question
c'est de faire entrer l'accès aux droits
à l'aide actif à mourir par les
pathologies en fait c'est le rapport que
l'individu a avec sa maladie qui compte
comment lui va son expérience propre de
la maladie que ce soit bien polyhandicap
que ce soit une pathologie incurable
immortelle etc donc le danger serait de
dire
tous les malades par exemple toutes les
personnes atteintes de la mairie de
Charcot auraient le droit systématique à
l'euthanasie ça serait formidablement
dangereux donc on peut pas rentrer sur
cette question là
alors c'est quand même la réalité qu'il
faut le regarder les soignants que moi
la question du droit pour moi est
beaucoup moins importante que la
question de comment on va prendre en
charge au quotidien la volonté exprimée
par les patients qui veulent mourir
l'idée est moins une technique juridique
que tout simplement d'équiper et les
professionnels de santé et tous ceux qui
sont dans l'entourage proche de ces
personnes à recevoir une demande
personnelle d'aide activée recevoir une
de recevoir c'est une question de
capacité empathique c'est une capacité
d'imagination la capacité imaginative à
se mettre à la place d'autrui pour
savoir comment il vit son expérience de
la maladie autrement dit j'ai entendu
dire qu'effectivement c'était un jeu de
société un enjeu politique pour moi
c'est un jeu incroyablement humain la
question c'est quelle place on donne à
l'écoute de la vulnérabilité d'autrui et
la ville était d'autrui c'est pas que la
réalité du Pacifique en premier la
volonté du patient est-ce qu'elle doit
être première parce qu'on entend la
volonté du patient la société et
peut-être même quelque chose qui nous
échappe est-ce que le patient doit avant
tout arriver dans cette réflexion comme
en première ligne du souci de
législateur Philippe Gosselin je crois
qu'on peut rappeler qu'il y a un
équilibre à trouver et ça a été dit par
Alain Klein il y a un conflit d'éthique
finalement
l'éthique de la vulnérabilité l'éthique
de l'autonomie comment on trouve cet
équilibre
à la personne
n'appartient pas totalement et en
premier lieu à la personne qui peut-être
mourante n'oublions pas aussi l'effet
cascade sur sa famille sur ses proches
et et donc la mort n'est pas un acte
isolé quand on fait société quand on
fait famille fratrie la décision que je
prends elle rejaillit sur sur les autres
et puis il y a aussi un interdit qui
reste fort et ça me paraît plutôt
heureux c'est que donner la mort est une
transgression et reste une transgression
donc l'équilibre est à trouver les
lignes rouges fixées
rouges la question se pose aussi elle a
été posée sans réponse par les membres
de la Convention de savoir si ça
pourrait s'appliquer aux enfants mineurs
la Belgique a déjà répondu depuis
plusieurs années à ce sujet le président
l'a écarté les conventionnelles
mais ce n'est pas le président qui fera
la loi c'est le Parlement jusqu'à preuve
du contraire et donc je veux aussi que
sur ces questions on prenne le temps et
qu'on n'est pas d'une certaine façon
aussi une injonction sociale quand on a
tel ou telle maladie que ce soit Charcot
ou d'autres qu'on ait une forme
d'injonction à dire à finalement je suis
à charge et il faut que je disparaisse
pour libérer mes proches vous voyez
c'est tout ce sont tous ces éléments là
qui sont aussi très fragiles et
apprendre en considération
j'imagine que les citoyens ont beaucoup
regardé l'application de la loi avant de
savoir s'il fallait la faire évoluer on
découvre que c'est sédations profondes
et continuent jusqu'au décès sous
critère très strict c'est l'innovation
majeure de cette dernière loi peuvent
prendre des jours voir des semaines le
Conseil d'État avait même écrit
des mourants qui n'en finissent pas de
mourir en 2018 ça c'est un tolérable
pour les familles pour les soignants
aussi ça veut dire qu'il y a un problème
aujourd'hui non
ouais alors peut-être juste pour réagir
ce qui est important quand même et je
les je veux le redire parce que dans le
travail de la Convention il a jamais été
question de dire que certains pouvaient
être un poids pour la société enfin il
vous l'avez vu d'ailleurs je sais mais
je le redis mais dans la conclusion des
travaux ils ont bien insisté là-dessus
il s'agit de demander une aide active à
mourir pour les personnes qui les ont
des situations bien particulières mais à
aucun moment de partir dans des dérives
eugénistes c'est pas du tout ça et ça
bien évidemment ça a été extrêmement
important pour eux et par exemple vous
parlez de la question des mineurs la
question s'est posée pour les mineurs
ils ont beaucoup discuté de ce sujet
avec le premier des critères finalement
pour eux était la question des
souffrances notamment des souffrances
réfractaires et quand on voit les débats
au sein du 16e certains le disent après
tout pourquoi est-ce que
tout traitement pourquoi est-ce que un
mineur devrait souffrir et pas un majeur
donc il y a ces questions là qui sont
posées mais là où je trouve que ça
montre aussi la qualité et le sérieux de
ses travaux c'est qu'à la fin ils se
sont dit ok sur la question des mineurs
on ne peut pas être conclusif c'est trop
sensible en fait et parce que c'est trop
sensible on préfère se dire voilà c'est
pas à nous tranche fin si jamais un
autre tranché mais en tout cas c'est sur
ce point-là on n'a pas à aller plus loin
et donc ce premier débat s'achève qu'au
départ la loi belge en 2002 avait décidé
en disant que il ne pouvait pas rentrer
sur cette question là pour les mineurs
et depuis il y a quand même eu 3 mineurs
qui ont pu avoir accès parce que ils ont
fait évoluer le cadre législatif donc la
question véritablement qu'il faut se
poser c'est en tout cas ce que le chef
de l'État doit à mon avis il doit se
poser comme question est-ce qu'il vaut
une autorisation sous conditions ou
maintenir une interdiction avec des
exceptions et l'exception ne se définit
jamais à l'avance c'est toujours dans
une analyse circonstancielle justement
des circonstances qu'on fait
l'exceptionnalité d'une situation quel
est votre sentiment
peut-être donc il faut encore prendre
son temps pour réfléchir
on va terminer ce débat avec les
soignants qui vont nous rejoindre dans
un instant mais petite question Olivier
Falorni le prochain reportage on vous a
suivi dans une unité de soins palliatifs
on est frappé quand même par
l'opposition des soignants
particulièrement soit palliatifs mais
pas seulement comment vous les sentez
est-ce que ils sont tous opposés ou
c'est plus nuancé je pense que c'est
plus nuancé beaucoup plus nuancé
je crois que il serait effectivement
assez assez injuste de d'opposer
soignants et citoyens parce que les
soignants sont des citoyens et j'ai pu
mesurer aussi la grande difficulté de de
certains confrontés à la sédation
profondé continue on parle des mineurs
vous savez il y a aussi un travail de
parlementaire qui a été fait en 2021 je
vais faire ma propre publicité mais j'ai
défendu une proposition de loi qui a été
débattue et qui avait écarté les mineurs
mais lorsque nous sommes allés à
l'hôpital de Saint-Denis un médecin
réanimateur en néonat nous expliquer
qu'il avait sédation profonde et
continue à nourrisson et cela faisait
huit jours cela faisait huit jours
d'aborder ce sujet et à l'époque en 2021
sur la proposition de loi que j'avais
faite nous avions écarté la question des
mineurs mais le problème se pose pour
autant et j'ai encore en souvenir
l'audition de Jean Leonetti qui avait
évoqué la question des des nourrissons
et qui avait éventuellement laissé
entendre que c'était peut-être la
problématique la plus difficile à
traiter mais peut-être celle qui
pourrait ouvrir une exception de ta nazi
on va s'arrêter là on va accueillir les
soignants merci beaucoup on a tous
compris qu'au fond selon travail va
continuer à cheminer qu'il faudra du
temps et d'une main tremblante et c'est
vous qui aurait la responsabilité finale
du vote merci beaucoup direction l'unité
de soins palliatifs de Juvisy en région
parisienne ou la mission parlementaire
la vôtre Olivier falhermit s'est rendu
pour évaluer l'application de cette loi
clese Leonetti deuxième reportage de
Céline crispy avec Gilles lepetre et
Bernard et Bertrand Martineau
hôpital de Juvisy en région parisienne à
côté des urgences il y a un service où
on ne guérit pas on soulage
l'unité des soins palliatifs
une commission qui doit juger si la
façon dont on meurt aujourd'hui en
France est acceptable
bienvenue Didier Martin quel rapporteur
en 20 ans la France s'est dotée de
quatre lois sur la fin de vie la
dernière date de 2016
notre rôle c'est évaluer l'application
de la loi kless Leonetti d'en voir les
failles éventuelles ce que nous voulons
c'est comment faire en sorte que
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie soit
le plus doux possible le plus
respectueux possible
un simple inventaire du service suffit à
comprendre l'un des problèmes majeurs de
la prise en charge de la fin de vie dans
notre pays
deux médecins s'occupaient des divides
soins palliatifs de praticiens
hospitaliers est en plein mais ça c'est
en théorie c'est ce qu'on devrait dans
la vraie vie elle est toute seule et
encore elle s'occupe d'une autre unité
dans l'étage
côté infirmière les effectifs font du
quand tu arrives ici il y avait beaucoup
plus de soignants il y avait aucun
patient qui décidait seul quand il y
avait un patient qui était voilà en
train de partir on se détachait petit à
petit ce nombre il a diminué maintenant
on est deux par jour deux infirmières
par jour j'enlève mon masque c'est
maintenant quand il y a un patient qui
est en train de partir c'est difficile
de se détacher
parce que la collègue reste toute seule
pour 10 patients
persiste ce sentiment de ne pas pouvoir
faire son travail correctement ce matin
une vieille dame m'a tout à coup montré
des signes de tristesse
il faut qu'on passe très souvent parce
qu'on voit qu'elle est bien avec quand
il y a quelqu'un elle est bien ce matin
il n'était pas bien on a fini la
toilette on est parti on est revenu même
pas on a fait juste une toilette elle
était décédée et c'est dans peut-être il
serait mieux décédé si elle avait
quelqu'un à côté d'elle peut-être
qu'elle pourrait même mourir avec le
sourire quoi et moi ça ça m'a fait mal
au cœur ce matin
je voulais vous poser une question très
directe est-ce qu'il y a des situations
où malgré tout les douleurs sont
réfractaires à tout traitement
on phase terminale quand le patient
souffre trop la loi a introduit un
laisser mourir sans permettre le faire
mourir est-ce que vous pratiquez
régulièrement ou pas
ce nouveau droit qui est celui de la
sédation profonde jusqu'au décès
un certain stade de passer aux pratiques
de l'acidation
la sédation consiste à endormir un
malade et à ne plus le nourrir ni
l'hydrater jusqu'au décès un entre deux
entre vie et morts pas toujours bien
vécu par les familles c'est d'ailleurs
une des limites de la loi que les
députés vont découvrir
vous avez le fruit de la décision
patient conscient cancer mes tests
terminale très douloureux etc les
proches sont informés ils passent un
moment ensemble
on se dit au revoir on est en place la
sédation
si au bout de trois jours les choses
sont toujours stables malade d'or ne
souffre pas trop qu'est-ce que vous
faites vous continuez vous augmentez les
doses si le patient est stable on
dépasse pas les doses nécessaires on va
pas forcer à partir du moment où le
patient il est confortable et qu'il y a
aucun signe de souffrance
pendant quel but en fait ça peut durer
certains temps ça peut être Disney ça
nous est déjà arrivé des familles qui me
le demandent vous pouvez pas faire
quelque chose
pousser les seringues non désolé ils
auront pas de réponse favorable les
chaînes
alors forcément ici on imagine pas que
la loi puisse évoluer vers une
autorisation à l'aide active à mourir
moins injecter un produit létal j'aurais
mauvaise conscience
c'est pas à moi à donner la mort à
quelqu'un alors que moi j'ai signé pour
prendre soin de l'autre et pas pour le
faire mourir peut-être que la loi
évoluera
versus pourquoi pas le lieu des soins
palliatifs en tout cas l'hospitalisation
ne sera pas forcément le lieu
c'est ce message là qu'on essaie de vous
passer parce que nous notre mission
n'est pas celle-là en tout cas pour
l'instant
pourtant du côté des patients cette
demande d'étendre la loi existe
les députés ne verront qu'un seul malade
du service
mais spontanément c'est le patient qui
va aborder le sujet avec eux
bonjour Monsieur Olivier falornier donc
nous sommes députés tous les deux
et ce qu'il y a des moments où vous vous
sentez que vous souffrez trop
est-ce que vous pensez que il faudrait
faire une loi pour les personnes qui
sont dans la même situation que vous
quelle loi il faudrait faire
qu'on vous aide à partir oui tu es
vraiment con c'est que
dans le débat les représentants des
soins palliatifs toujours combattu les
partisans de l'aide activa mourir une
opposition qui n'aurait pas lieu d'être
selon le député
les soins palliatifs doivent être
confortés dans ce pays et s'il devait y
avoir une loi
ouvrant le droit à l'aide d'activer à
mourir pour autant il faudrait si j'ose
dire dans le même temps
conforter et renforcer
l'accompagnement en soins palliatifs en
donnant des moyens humains et financiers
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé en
Belgique quand le pays a autorisé le
thanazi il y a 20 ans il a dans le même
temps renforcer ses services de soins
palliatifs
et voilà donc pour ce reportage signé
Céline crispy nous ont rejoint sur ce
plateau Alexis Burnot bonsoir bonjour
merci d'être là vous êtes médecin chef
du service de soins palliatifs à
l'Institut Curie Paris membre de la
safap la société française
d'accompagnement et de soins palliatifs
opposés à l'évolution de la loi bonsoir
Valérie ménage merci d'être là vous êtes
neurologue hospitalière spécialisé dans
la prise en charge des maladies neuro
dégénératives anciennes chargées de
mission au Centre national des soins
palliatifs et de la fin de vie
favorables à l'évolution de la loi
bonsoir Yves Delock merci d'être là vous
êtes médecin généraliste belge vous
pratiquez à Bruxelles la Belgique qui a
légalisé l'euthanasie en 2002 vous êtes
l'auteur de plusieurs livres sur le
sujet et vous voyez on le verra tout à
l'heure dans un reportage régulièrement
des patients français traversés la
frontière pour vous demander cette aide
active à mourir bonsoir Damien Legay
merci à vous de participer à ces
missions vous êtes philosophe
spécialiste des questions éthiques
opposées
présentation la réanimation la dialyse
et fantastique mais en même temps
abandonner laisser sur le carreau des
gens qui étaient en fin de vie ou
s'acharner ou parfois poser des
cocktails en particulier quand les
familles étaient
généralisation le renforcement des soins
palliatifs on va venir comment on
traverse ça quand on parle
personnellement ce que je veux dire
c'est que nous avons vu que en prenant
un chemin sans le faire mourir sans
prolonger la vie et et en prenant soin
tout le temps sous l'agent toujours
qu'il y avait des possibles chaque jour
et que ce temps qui peut paraître
inutile
et bien finalement pouvait pour une
majorité de gens avoir de la valeur nous
avons des témoignages forts donc quand
on a donc cet acte là quel qu'il soit au
fond passif ou actif ne peut pas relever
de soins c'est pour vous impossible en
tout cas cette demande-là c'est toujours
d'une personne qui a eu un parcours une
histoire et il faut se poser avec cette
personne et comprendre qu'est-ce qui
fait qu'elle en arrive faire cette
demande et déjà vous pouvez pas savoir
combien on comprend qu'il puisse y avoir
cette demande et et ensemble quand on
montre ce qui est possible quand on la
soulage quand on puisse quand on peut
lui donner les possibilités elle change
je dis elle disparaît très souvent je
dis pas qu'elle disparaît toujours mais
elle disparaît très souvent et donc
c'est ce qui nous motive en tout cas à
pas dire comme ça oui bien sûr oui non
l'euthanasie voilà Valérie ménage
racontez-nous vous comme praticienne ce
moment bien particulier lorsque l'un de
vos passions vous dit je ne peux plus je
ne veux plus qu'est-ce qui se passe donc
on est effectivement dans ces parcours
dans dans ce qui est mon expérience de
maladie neurodégénérative où il y a eu
par essence déjà une prise en charge
palliative puisqu'on sait qu'on ne va
pas les guérir et pour autant ils ont
mis en place un certain nombre de
stratégies pour pouvoir continuer à
vivre pleinement et donc quand il nous
dépose cette demande c'est effectivement
dans une temporalité qui est déjà très
avancée où ils ont déjà perdu
accepter les deuils de temps de choses
et ils le sont d'autant plus que c'est
rarement une demande de mort ils veulent
vivre mais force et de constater qu'ils
ne peuvent plus vivre alors ce qui est
important pour le coup dans mon
expérience aussi de ces demandes qui
nous sont faites depuis toujours et qui
sont pas liés à l'innovation
thérapeutique parce que malheureusement
dans les maladies neurodégénératives
force et de constater que on en est
toujours à peu près au même point ce qui
est important à noter c'est que la
sédation profonde et continue jusqu'au
décès elle a permis d'accompagner
autrement ces personnes ne serait-ce que
lorsqu'il était question des demandes de
limitation thérapeutique en sachant et
c'est important aussi la demande
d'arrêter le traitement arrêter un
traitement on la demande de patient face
à ces situations terribles où ils ne
sont plus en capacité de manger par
exemple et où la question va se poser
est-ce que vous souhaitez une nutrition
artificielle oui non et quand ils disent
non avant on pouvait rien faire d'autre
que d'attendre un symptôme d'inconfort
et je voudrais peut-être insister
là-dessus aussi pour dire que cette
sédation profonde et continue elle n'est
pas une pratique soignante comme les
autres ça n'est pas la pratique sédative
qu'on pouvait être amené à proposer par
le passé quand il y avait effectivement
des symptômes qui guidés nos soins là
c'est une
un paradigme nouveau qui s'est imposé à
nous c'est à dire que c'est la personne
qui nous demandait et en ce sens on est
finalement dans une expérience assez
proche de l'aide active à mourir qui est
que c'est la personne qui demande et le
médecin qui concentre et là on a eu
effectivement des rites qui étaient que
la personne pouvait demander le jour
l'heure de l'arrêt du traitement et de
la mise en place de la sédation pour
autant il y a aussi des limites à cette
sédation sur le terrain quand on a
effectivement c'est cette année
qui demande à être arrêté c'est la
nutrition ça peut être très long et on
peut espérer que le patient n'en souffre
pas puisqu'il est sédaté mais pour la
famille et les soignants les soignants
souffrent aussi de cette situation de la
loi de la loi actuelle Yves Delock vous
comme médecin vous la pratiquez
cette euthanasie ce geste létal en
Belgique et depuis l'OTAN comment vous
vivez ça on peut pas rester insensible
même si ça fait des années que que vous
le faites
puis tout à fait d'accord c'est au
niveau émotionnel je pense que pour moi
c'est peut-être ce que j'ai fait de plus
perturbant quand je pratique une
euthanasie après tout le chemin qu'on a
décrit
l'émotion est très forte l'émotion
d'être en face du patient avec qui j'ai
établi un espèce de contrat moral et
[Musique]
mon émotion est très forte l'émotion de
la famille qui entoure est très forte
également le patient qui s'en va
n'arrête pas de nous dire merci vous
auriez dû le faire six mois plus tôt le
patient est parti je me retrouve seul
avec la famille qui pleure le médecin
pleure aussi l'émotion est très forte
mais je voudrais ajouter que en même
temps chez moi il y a une certaine
sérénité quand je quitte l'hôpital où je
pratique des euthanasies je me dis il a
retrouvé si j'ose dire pardonne-moi pour
le mot sa liberté j'ai répondu à sa
demande il a fait tout un parcours il
est venu à mon bureau etc on parlait des
gens qui sont en demande j'étais très
étonné encore hier de voir des patients
arriver à mon cabinet à Bruxelles
demandez l'ouverture d'un dossier pas
nécessairement et quand je leur dis ok
ils vont voir d'autres médecins votre
dossier est en ordre et répond aux
critères de la loi belge il y a un
soulagement énorme du patients et je
n'entendrai peut-être plus jamais parler
de mais ils savent que si un jour ça ne
va plus il y a toujours pas de de
changement dans la loi française ils
pourront compter sur nous on y reviendra
vous avez prononcé le mot de liberté
Damien Legay la maladie et la mort
appartient aux patients et pas aux
médecins c'est un médecin qui le dit
Jean-François delfresci récemment chez
nos confrères de France Inter le
président du Comité consultatif national
d'éthique vous êtes d'accord
oui non si vous voulez parce que la
question c'est est-ce que
l'accompagnement en fin de vie est-ce
que l'autorisation de la désactive à
mourir de l'euthanasie est une question
individuelle ou est aussi une question
collective il me semble c'est une
question collective on le voit bien si
vous voulez par exemple en Belgique donc
j'entends bien tout ce qui est dit voyez
la question n'est pas de savoir qui a
tort ou qui a raison tout le monde a
raison dire que une solution serait de
nature à être parfaite d'un côté comme
de l'autre de manière à éteindre les
hypocrisies les souffrances les
difficultés ça serait absurde donc c'est
une question me semble-t-il qu'il faut
poser en termes de moindre mal qu'est-ce
qui est le moins mauvais c'est pas la
question de ce qui est bon au nom de
quoi au nom au nom justement c'est pour
ça que ça m'intéresse que que
le Canadien en Belgique soit évoqué
parce que les en Belgique c'est non mais
allez-y allez-y parce que on a un
reportage mais à vous montrer sur la
Belgique mais je
comme vous voulez et c'est justement si
vous voulez le problème c'est que
l'exception à la française dont parle le
président de la République ce que l'on
pense que tout le monde dit ce que la
convention citoyenne pense que le CCNE
indique comme quoi on serait susceptible
parce qu'on est plus malin que les
autres de pouvoir encadrer et tenir dans
le marbre l'encadrement et la
possibilité d'avoir une euthanie
tellement réglementée tellement
surveillée tellement bien que ça ne
bougerait pas donc pour vous c'est
ouvrir la boîte de Pandore si on
l'égalise l'euthanasie on aura des
demandes d'euthanasie quoi exponentielle
vous croyez vraiment qu'il pense c'est
l'expérience qui le dit on comprend très
bien qu'il y a une opposition très forte
entre le corps médical après il y a des
médecins qui sont qui sont d'accord pour
faire le geste et donc accepter si loi
nouvelle il y a c'est sûr mais la
tactile à mourir donc c'est c'est pas si
tranché c'est pas une opposition massive
du corps médical ça vous vous êtes
réflexion d'accord avec ça
je crois que les personnes qui sont
autour de la table et qui s'expriment
les soignants la philosophe c'est de la
diversité de la société française
aujourd'hui qui s'est exprimée à la
convention qui s'est même exprimé au
Comité consultatif national d'éthique il
y a 8 membres du comité nationalétique
non ils sont pas retrouvés dans nos
conclusions je crois que tous des bas se
déroulent et vous la voir en tête à un
moment où il y a un malaise très profond
dans la communauté médicale
je crois qu'il faut en tenir compte en
pleine crise de l'hôpital en pleine
c'est pas uniquement l'hôpital c'est
l'hôpital des EHPAD la prise en charge à
domicile et donc c'est vrai qu'en
dépression fait cette réflexion en
disant la priorité cette patient mais
effectivement il y a l'équipe médicale
et dans ce débat
plus je chemine j'étais un des auteurs
de loi 2016 j'en connais des limites
j'en connais les limites mais je
considère que ça a été une avancée mais
je reprendrai votre expression
c'est pas un débat entre la vie et la
mort
dans tous les cas qu'on évoque la mort
elle est là
et pour reprendre une expression d'un
collègue philosope Frédéric Vans qui dit
c'est choisir pour la personne le chemin
le moins pire vous l'avez presque repris
le mot pour vous c'est là notre débat
alors
allez-y dernière chose et l'autre débat
que nous avons pas tranché le CC que la
convention citoyenne n'a pas tranché ils
ont posé des questions si on va sous une
forme qui reste à déterminer l'aide vers
l'aide active à mourir on a fait des
propositions
la question qui se pose et elle est
normale au-delà au-delà de la clause de
conscience quelle est la place du
médecin et de l'équipe soignante
je précise les choses pour ceux qui nous
regardent mais je pense qu'ils ont bien
compris ou le geste létal est fait par
le patio lui-même avec l'aide d'une
association c'est le modèle suisse ou le
modèle beige ou l'intervention d'un
tiers est nécessaire et c'est évidemment
le médecin le plus souvent dans le cadre
de l'hôpital mais il y a des il y a des
on comprend bien que s'il y a réticence
il faudra une cause de conscience ça
tout le monde le garantit une clause de
conscience qu'on peut opposer quand on
ne veut pas faire ce geste si la
légalisation de l'aide actif va mourir
et décider c'est bien d'accord est-ce
qu'il y aura assez de médecin on peut on
peut en douter ou il y en aura tout le
monde souhaite
évidemment quelques conscience je crois
que personne s'est opposé à ça dans le
parcours qu'il est le mien comme médecin
ne soit pas collectif nous avons nous
faisons tout pour accompagner la
personne jusqu'au bout je veux pas dire
que je serai en manque d'une clause de
conscience
l'idée d'aller faire mourir quelqu'un
pour les soignants pour une majorité de
soignants en tout cas pour les soignants
ne sont pas les tifs c'est plutôt no Go
dans dans l'échange que nous avons en ce
moment parce que nous pour vous les
soins palliatifs pour bien comprendre
étaient renforcés qui en avait 100%
d'accès sur tout le territoire il y
aurait plus de demandes plus de demandes
à mourir c'est une question que je vous
adore parce que nous sommes pas des
magiciens nous ne rajeunissons pas les
gens nous n'avons pas une famille
aimante à celui qui n'en a pas nous
n'empêchons pas quelqu'un d'avoir peur
de vivre une fragilité un handicaper
leur autonomie et qui serait frappé
d'une maladie incurable
cela vous pensez que en soins palliatifs
en tout cas comme ça en une seconde je
peux pas dire j'entends mes collègues
qui vivent des choses différentes des
miennes moi je suis dans un service de
cancérologie d'autres dans les services
de neurologie ils vivent des choses
différentes et les lignes bougent sans
doute mais aujourd'hui dire vous êtes
pour de faire mourir quelqu'un sur
rendez-vous mardi à non après il y a il
y a peut-être la loi le dira sans doute
il y aura peut-être des nuances un
examen pour chaque situation en tout cas
ce qui me paraît absolument
incontournable c'est d'aller à chaque
fois reprendre l'historique des gens
quelqu'un qui vient demander qu'on le
fasse mourir ce n'est pas rien il peut
le demander parce qu'il a handicap
terrible et qu'il n'en peut plus on a vu
aussi qu'il y a des gens qui le
demandent parce qu'ils considèrent
qu'ils ont suffisamment vécu entre les
deux il y a toujours quelque chose à
comprendre il y a une histoire des gens
et parfois
avec eux j'ai confiance je continue tout
le monde est d'accord pour dire qu'il
faut renforcer les soins palliatifs je
voudrais qu'on aille là-dessus c'est
renforcer la culturation palliative la
culture
palliatifs tous les professionnels de
santé ça c'est vraiment le préalable pas
le préalable à une évolution de
détective à mourir parce qu'il faudrait
pas considérer qu'il y aurait une sorte
de pré-requis les demandes des
détectives à mourir elles existent
depuis toujours et pour le coup dans les
pays qui ont des pénalisé la dactive à
mourir ce qu'on peut en tout cas
observer c'est que la majorité de ceux
qui s'inscrivent dans cette demande sont
pris en charge en soins palliatifs c'est
plus de 80% des données du Canada ou les
personnes avaient des soins palliatifs
et pour 50% d'entre eux depuis plus d'un
mois donc il faut pas réduire la demande
de l'active à mourir comme étant
finalement un défaut d'accès aux soins
palliatifs parce que les faits ne disent
pas ça et par ailleurs ce qui emporte me
semble-t-il dans le débat qui nous anime
et où il faudrait qu'on se mette tous
ensemble à reconnaître cela c'est la
reconnaissance de ces situations de
souffrance c'est elle qui aujourd'hui
nous interroge à finalement évoqué comme
on l'a dit que il pas finalement un
choix entre deux morts et le fait de
donner la mort peut-il être
effectivement une visée de soulager la
souffrance quand tout résiste c'est la
souffrance qui est au cœur de la demande
alors quelle est le modèle français de
la fin de vie qu'elle pourrait être ce
modèle puisque le président de la
République appelle les députés les
citoyens à le co-construire on va
prendre donc l'exemple de la Belgique et
vous allez voir et bien que Céline
crispy a suivi impatient Français
Sylvain docteur Delock que vous avez
accompagné il souffrait d'une sclérose
en plaques reportage
j'ai 32 ans je vais atteindre sclérose
en plaques PT diagnostiqué en 2011 et
depuis mon état se dégrade petit à part
les organes du terrain et maintenant je
vois contraint d'envisager la fin de vie
pour rester digne avant de avant de plus
maîtriser mon mes actions
beaucoup de
aujourd'hui c'est juste une ouverture de
dossier médical
donc c'est
un premier rendez-vous
c'est juste devant une porte de sortie
quand on est à sera dégradé et intégral
je sais que je pourrais prendre une
deuxième rendez-vous pour terminer
c'est une décision qui était dur à
prendre mais maintenant on est prise et
on va
vous souffrez
d'une sclérose en plaques crémitante
secondaire progressive oui
sclérose de quoi souffrez-vous le plus
la perte d'autonomie
de faire tous les petits gestes de la
vie
tout seul dans un appartement vous avez
une fille j'ai vu oui elle est au
courant de votre démarche
quand j'aurai fait ce rendez-vous je
vais pas lui en parler avant d'avoir
enclenché le premier rendez-vous et la
10 ans
la fin c'est le pas une paralysie totale
et je veux
c'est qu'on trouve un nouveau remède non
n'y croyez pas quelques décennies qu'on
recherche
moi je souhaite mettre fin à ma vie
quand je veux c'est une décision qui
vient de vous
c'est vous qui allez à jour dire voilà
je n'en peux plus ma vie n'est que
souffrance je souhaite pouvoir
bénéficier d'une euthanasie et c'est
quand je veux sinon un mois un an oui
c'est ça le tanasie en elle-même vous
allez arriver à l'hôpital les
infirmières installent une perfusion et
c'est nous il y a un autre médecin qui
le fait avec moi je suis pas seul à
décider donc votre dossier est ouvert
pour moi c'est bon vous êtes dans les
règles de la loi belge il y aura le
document du psychiatre il y aura le
troisième médecin qui va
assister faire l'euthanasier avec moi
que je veux
donc vous aurez été vu par trois
médecins
c'est un service que vous demandez
en tout cas
c'est une décision personnelle qui
regarde comment personne ne le droit
d'essayer pour moi c'est une liberté qui
est pour moi ça fait des années que je
me bats un moment donné on a envie de
partir
la liberté de disposer de leur corps en
France dès que possible
pour ce sujet de Céline Crespy et depuis
ce tournage Sylvain est décédé en
février dernier en Belgique Yves Delock
des patients français comme Sylvain il y
en a beaucoup qui viennent vous voir
nous avons des appels de trois fois par
semaine de patients qui veulent t'ouvrir
un dossier en Belgique qui
malheureusement font des centaines de
kilomètres pour venir jusque dans notre
pays
la spécificité du modèle belge il faut
peut-être le préciser c'est le
discernement éclairé le jour J il y a
des garde-fous lesquels précisément
les garde-fous sont évidemment les
critères de la loi belge qui est
tellement critiquée
mais donc les critères une demande du
patient répétée les
certificats médicaux prouvant évidemment
que il est atteint d'une maladie ou
d'une affection grave et incurable ça
c'est indispensable pour respecter les
critères de la loi et des souffrances
inapaisables malgré de multiples
traitements et il faut que au moment où
le geste est opéré le patient puisse
réitérer sur discernement c'est bien ça
sa volonté
Damien Legay vous aviez commencé à
parler de ce modèle bergeant dans une
grande partie des cas les passions
demandent demandent l'aide médicale on
le voit bien
il faut dire plusieurs choses la
première c'est que
les autorités belges disent elles-mêmes
qui à peu près il y a 20 étrangers par
an qui bénéficient en Belgique de
l'euthanasie dont ils ont dit français
10 sur 650 000 morts il y en a 40 il y
en a 40 en Belgique qui il y en a 40 ans
en Suisse pardon qui bénéficient de la
fin de justice par an donc c'est des
chiffres si si c'est des chiffres qui
sont qui sont extrêmement ils ont pas la
possibilité de dire combien il y a de
français puisque le lieu d'habitation
est anonyme et que la seule manière
qu'on peut qu'on puisse présumer que ce
soit des patients français c'est si le
médecin lui-même l'indique dans la
partie qui elle remonte à la Commission
de contrôle et le dernier chiffre en
2021 c'était 60 patients étrangers à peu
près dont 50 français en sachant que
c'est largement sous-estimé puisque ça
n'est que si le médecin l'inscrit dans
le volet
non anonyme qu'on aura cette information
comme il y a Leguet donc je dis première
chose c'est très peu de personnes d'une
deuxièmement et je vous remettrai si
vous voulez un document que la FAP vient
de sortir sur sur le dit modèle belge
vous avez un effectivement depuis 20 ans
vous avez une extension des ayant droit
à l'euthanasie qui est absolument
considérable il y a eu 16 ou 17
changements de la loi deuxièmement la
Corée des droits de l'homme je viens de
le dire juste avant sanctionner la
Belgique parce que justement il y a une
absence de contrôle une absence de
contrôle parce que il y a une
déclaration pour vous c'est le modèle à
ne pas suivre non mais juste je vous dis
juste que j'entends les griefs
et en plus à ça on rajoute ce que ce que
ce que dit la sphin parce que disent
tous ceux qui voient ce qu'il en est qui
a effectivement une sous-déclaration
donc il y a à peu près 30% de tanasie
supplémentaire donc ça veut dire que si
vous voulez c'est un mécanisme c'est un
mécanisme qui fait que à partir du
moment où et j'entends bien ce que dit
frédéric Worms que vous que vous avez
cité à partir du moment où on donne le
droit on donne le droit
avec tous les encadrements que l'on veut
on sait c'est pas juste
une mauvaise prédiction on sait qu'il y
aura extension des droits qui aura
augmentation des ayants droits qu'il y
aura absence de contrôle tout ça on le
sait donc c'est pour ça que l'idée
d'avoir une un modèle français qui soit
tellement exceptionnel qu'on puisse le
graver dans le marbre c'est une illusion
absolue alors c'est la fin de ce débat
il touche à certains on va faire un
dernier tour de table à l'inclès on
entend on entend juste quand même que
l'euthanasie n'est pas attendu c'est
loin qu'on puisse dire par les soins
palliatifs le suicide assisté il y a
quand même une prescription médicale
mais le produit létal est acheté à la
pharmacie par le patient serait-il plus
approprié au regard de réticence
on n'est pas là autour de la table à
faire la loi ou à se battre sur des
chiffres
je crois qu'on est confronté un sujet à
la fois très simple et très compliqué
et j'ai compris ce qu'a voulu dire le
président de la République sur le modèle
français
on a une demande de société
qui n'est pas qui ne se traduit pas par
les sondages qui ne veulent rien dire
mais il y a une demande sociétale qui
est reprise tout sensibilité politique
aujourd'hui qui est reprise qui est
portée par un grand nombre de députés
plus de 300 députés donc il y a cette
réalité sociétale
je crois que personne ne peut l'ignorer
et l'examiner
et je pense réellement que c'est pas un
choix simplificateur de comme des
slogans ces choix entre la vie ou la
mort non c'est pour des personnes des
hommes et des femmes à un moment qu'elle
est de parcours le moins pire alors
qu'on est souvent vous avez raison
Madame pris en charge par des soins
palliatifs et donc je reviens
le travail que législateur va devoir
faire c'est de trouver un bon équilibre
entre la solidarité de la nation et ce
qui est indispensable les soins
palliatifs madame ce n'est pas que de
l'argent c'est la formation des médecins
c'est la formation continue c'est à
l'inseum des laboratoires de recherche
qui n'existaient pas il y a deux modèles
l'euthanasie on a compris le suicide
assisté Valérie ménage vous avez
travaillé les deux cas les deux sujets
absolument et de rappeler que dans le
cadre des troubles neurologiques il y
aurait effectivement quelque chose
d'inconcevable que d'imaginer un excès
unique au suicide assisté quand on sait
que pour bon nombre des patients
attendent maladie neurologiques ils ne
peuvent pas le faire que par ailleurs on
restreint sur une temporalité de
pronostic vital engagés à moyen terme
bon nombre de ces patients seraient
exclus de fait parce qu'il y a aussi
cette double peine qui est non seulement
la perte d'autonomie mais aussi
l'altération des capacités de
discernement qui fait qu'ils feront la
demande en amont à un moment où ils ne
sont pas forcément en toute fin de vie
ça c'est un point important et puis il y
a aussi donc de ce fait le suicide
assisté ou le réserver un moyen terme en
exclu déjà beaucoup alors même que ce
sont ceux qui potentiellement sont les
plus demandeurs
si le suicide assisté était légalisé
vous feriez jouer votre clause de
conscience mais ce serait ce serait
enfin ce serait moins difficile de
prescrire que que de faire le geste je
rejoins ce qui viennent d'être dit c'est
immensément complexe
encore une fois nous sommes témoins de
gens qui parfois font la demande parce
qu'il n'arrive pas à se projeter ou en
tout cas la projection est difficile et
quand on passe du temps avec eux et ils
peuvent avoir envie de possible d'autres
qui résistent et ce que cette demande
qui persiste doit faire l'objet d'une
aide active à mourir par les mêmes qui
les soignent je pense que non mais je
pense qu'il faut aller travailler encore
ce sujet là qu'il y a des situations
éminemment différentes entre quelqu'un
qui n'a plus envie de vivre parce que
qui peut être seul ou qui trouve qu'il a
suffisant bien vécu qui a peur de la fin
de vie et l'autre qui a une maladie
neurologique très dégradée qui peut voir
chaque lendemain plus difficile je fais
la différence et probablement qu'il
faudrait qu'on travaille ces situations
là qu'on travaille ensemble parce que
c'est pas si oui non ou simpliste
de la décision puisque le président de
la République a promis un texte de loi
avant l'été je vais vous donner le mot
de la fin Yves de Locht voilà votre pays
allégiféré il y a longtemps il y a
plusieurs lois comment vous regardez ce
débat qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez au
fond législateur pour qu'il trouve le
juste équilibre
je vois c'est passé en français arriver
en Belgique atteint de ces maladies
neurodégénératives très graves ils
savent que malheureusement il y aura pas
de traitement que le retard va se
dégrader progressivement et ça va
devenir insupportable pour eux dois-je
leur dire quand je les vois dans mon
cabinet revenez l'année prochaine parce
que vous ne souffrez pas encore assez
vous n'êtes pas dans le cas de la loi
classe Leonetti par exemple
et ils savent très bien que dans un an
ils seront encore plus paralysés il
s'est tout front ils pourront plus me
parler donc je vois arriver ce genre de
patient et je me pose cette question
est-ce que je vais oser leur dire
non votre dossier n'est pas accepté
parce que votre souffrance n'est d'abord
je n'ai aucun droit de juger la
souffrance d'un anneau il sait très bien
comment ça va évoluer si la médecine
progresse peut-être qu'un jour on pourra
aider c'est malheureux patient mais je
suis obligé d’air ils ne vont pas
demander du jour où le lendemain une
euthanasie mais je suis obligé de leur
dire oui vous entrez dans les conditions
de la loi belge donc le curseur est
éminemment difficile
de la conventions ni du CCNE absolument
ouverture
quand le pronostic vital est engagé à
moyen terme et non plus à court terme
merci c'est un sujet vertigineux c'est
un sujet extrêmement grave et il faut
voilà le manier avec beaucoup de
précautions merci pour vos expertises à
l'inclès merci d'avoir été notre grand
témoin ce soir merci à vous tous c'est
la fin de cette soirée événement
consacrée à la fin de vie sur elle s'est
fait rester avec nous pour la suite de
nos programmes bonsoir
[Musique]